[Música]
en China avanzan las protestas contra la
política de cero covid la ONU pide las
autoridades que respeten el derecho a la
manifestación pacífica mientras el
Ministerio de exteriores del gigante
asiático asegura no estar informado de
las movilizaciones
Moscú niega que las tropas rusas vayan a
abandonar la central nuclear de Sa
polilla contradiciendo así informaciones
difundidas por kiev por otro lado las
autoridades ucranianas anunciaron que el
suministro energético está restablecido
en gran parte del territorio tras
Reparar los daños en la red causados por
los bombardeos rusos
en Italia tras el deslizamiento de
tierra del sábado en la isla de ISSSTE
ha causado por las Fuertes lluvias los
equipos de rescate buscan a cuatro
personas desaparecidas mientras el
número de víctimas mortales se eleva a 8
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos esta edición en
China porque este fin de semana en
ciudades como Beijing ugano Shangai
tuvieron lugar Las mayores protestas en
años decenas de personas manifestaron
contra la política de Cero cobits en
movilizaciones que han continuado este
lunes en Hong Kong la policía detuvo a
un número desconocido de participantes
de esta inédita contestación que estalló
a raíz de la muerte de 10 personas este
jueves en un incendio en yang del que
supuestamente no pudieron escapar debido
a los confinamientos en las marchas de
este fin de semana Se oyeron consignas
que van desde demandas de más libertad
de expresión hasta la renuncia del
presidente Chip y un grito unánime el
fin de la restricciones que empezaron
hace casi tres años Luis Muñoz con las
reacciones internacionales
extrañas protestas contra los
confinamientos en Beijing
Shanghai
[Aplausos]
o Hong Kong esto en China mientras en el
mundo las manifestaciones se extienden
al frente de las embajadas como en
Londres capital de Reino Unido y Tokio
capital de Japón pero más allá del
malestar los efectos son notables los
principales índices de Wall Street
abrieron a la baja el lunes y la
comunidad internacional empieza a
pronunciarse al respecto así habló el
canciller de Reino Unido bueno las
protestas contra el gobierno chino son
raras y cuando suceden creo que el mundo
debería Tomar nota pero sobre todo es el
gobierno chino el que debería Tomar nota
de forma similar se expresó el gobierno
alemán
hemos tomado nota de las noticias de
protestas en varias de las principales
ciudades chinas también de los informes
de acciones a veces violentas de las
fuerzas de seguridad contra los
manifestantes sobre el terreno
puedo decirles que por supuesto nuestra
embajada en Beijing así como nuestras
otras misiones diplomáticas en China
continúan observando la situación de
cerca la pasada semana a un incendio en
un edificio de urumkie capital de
shinyang causó 10 muertos los
manifestantes argumentaron que las
graves restricciones que impidieron a
los fallecidos escapar y su rechazo se
ha convertido en un clamor cada vez
mayor contra casi tres años de
confinamientos aún así el país continúa
con su política de cero covid
vamos con noticias de la guerra en
Ucrania porque el kremlin niega que las
tropas rusas estén preparando su salida
de la central nuclear de saporiya El
portavoz del gobierno ruso dimitrip
Scott rechazó así la información
difundida por la agencia nuclear
ucraniana este domingo que declaró tener
indicios de que las fuerzas rusas
abandonarían la central recordemos que
la mayor planta nuclear de Europa está
bajo control ruso desde el principio de
la invasión y de hecho ha sido escenario
de combates que han puesto en alerta a
la comunidad internacional una reciente
misión de la organización Internacional
de la energía atómica constató la
seguridad en la planta Aunque el jefe de
la agencia advirtió que se está jugando
con fuego
y en parte Gracias a otras de las
centrales nucleares las autoridades
ucranianas han restablecido el
suministro energético en gran parte del
país tras los ataques rusos de esta
semana en regiones como gerson los
ciudadanos vuelven a tener acceso al gas
y a la electricidad Eso sí en medio de
la devastación causada por los
bombardeos y las advertencias de que los
ataques rusos podrían repetirse Alba
Santana nos amplía
tras día sin gas ni electricidad el
ludmila antonenco y su hijo Alexander
vuelven a tener acceso a estos servicios
en su casa de que son tenemos gas
tenemos electricidad Ojalá tuviéramos
agua también para usar el baño
adecuadamente el 24 de noviembre una
bomba supuestamente rusa cayó sobre su
casa las ventanas saltaron por los aires
y una de las paredes colapsó ahora a
pesar de que la casa está en ruinas
madre e hijo siguen aquí porque no
tienen otro sitio donde ir
la ventana se llenó de luz todo se
iluminó luego hubo muchas explosiones
estábamos muy asustados Me alegro de que
Alexander siga aquí si hubiera caído
Entre 10 y 30 centímetros más hacia aquí
yo no estaría aquí pero tengo 82 años no
es para tanto
otros no tuvieron tanta suerte como
Lilia krishenko que perdió a sus dos
padres en ese mismo ataque
había mucho polvo no podía ver nada mi
hijo y yo nos escondimos en el baño hoy
a mi padre gritar diciéndome que llamar
a una ambulancia porque mi madre estaba
herida pero no había conexión
a pesar de que el gas y la electricidad
en los dos servicios más importantes de
cara al infierno se han restablecido los
ciudadanos de gerson no tienen acceso al
agua ni a otras redes como la de la
televisión además el presidente bolo de
mercelenski ha advertido a los
ucranianos que todavía no están a salvo
sabemos que los terroristas están
planeando nuevos ataques lo sabemos con
certeza y mientras tengan misiles
desafortunadamente no se calmarán
una situación complicada de cara al
invierno cada vez más cerca y para el
que los ucranianos sumidos en la guerra
no están preparados
en Italia continúan las tareas de
rescate tras el violento deslizamiento
de tierra en la turística isla de isquia
de este sábado los equipos de emergencia
buscan a cuatro desaparecidos mientras
se elevó a 8 el número de víctimas
mortales entre ellas se cuenta un recién
nacido expertos y activistas aseguran
que la construcción de edificios
ilegales aumentó los riesgos de
desastres naturales en esta zona insular
próxima al mar de la ciudad de Nápoles
más detalles en el siguiente informe
como si la colina se rompiera en pedazos
en pocas horas el lodo se adentró
cientos de metros en el mar Arrasando
todo a su paso Los buzos estuvieron
peinando las aguas de la costa italiana
de isquia con la ayuda de helicópteros
aquí es donde se encontró la primera
víctima una mujer de 31 años que
trabajaba en una tienda local hallada
muerta a cientos de metros de su casa
los bomberos están turnando para buscar
en la zona tratando de encontrar a los
desaparecidos pero la tarea sigue siendo
difícil en paralelo el gobierno decretó
el estado de emergencia lo que hace que
sea complejo es que nos encontramos bajo
la zona debilitada por el
desprendimiento las casas están llenas
de barro por lo que es muy complicado
Acceder al interior y continuar nuestra
búsqueda
alrededor de 200 personas fueron
desalojadas algunas se refugiaron en
este hotel cerca del puerto esta mujer
refugiada con su hijo y su nieta se
enteró de que su cuñada fue encontrada
muerta bajo los escombros
estamos tristes mantuve la esperanza
hasta el final otra tragedia en esta
ciudad y en esta familia no sé cómo voy
a afrontar los próximos días
[Música]
esta familia Tuvo más suerte su casa
sigue en pie a pocos metros de la
trayectoria de la luz
ves nuestra casa aquí pasó por allí y es
que recibió casi 13 centímetros de
lluvia en seis horas la mayor
precipitación en 20 años Este alud es el
tercer desastre natural que golpea la
isla ya víctima de un terremoto en 2017
y de mortales inundaciones en 2019
Emmanuel macrón participará en una
visita de estado a Estados Unidos desde
el martes por la noche hasta el viernes
es la Segunda visita del presidente
francés a Washington donde ya había sido
invitado por Donald Trump en 2018 entre
los temas importantes previstos en la
agenda están el ámbito espacial las
relaciones económicas y la francofonía
Gabriel colchen nos amplía
una invitación que es señal de buen
momento entre ambas naciones Emmanuel
Llegará el martes por la noche a
Washington para un viaje de tres días
con mucha pompa Esta visita es la
segunda invitación que recibe maku desde
2018 cuando lo invitó Donald Trump esta
será la primera visita de estado de la
Administración biden Harris pondrá de
relieve la profunda y duradera relación
entre Estados Unidos y Francia nuestro
más antiguo Aliado que se basa en los
valores democráticos que compartimos los
vínculos económicos y la cooperación en
materia de defensa y seguridad la
cuestión económica estará en el centro
de las conversaciones la ley de
reducción de la inflación firmada por el
presidente biden preocupa a Europa que
denuncia el proteccionismo
estadounidense París esperar limitar las
medidas destinadas a repatriar a Estados
Unidos las inversiones industriales
vinculadas con la transición energética
los temas espaciales y también serán
tratados la última etapa del viaje será
Nueva Orleans la ciudad fundada por el
francés
donde se hablara de la francofonía el
encuentro diplomático también contará
con una escena de estado de centenas de
personas en la cual participará la
delegación francesa compuesta por varios
ministros parlamentarios y
personalidades además de una acogida muy
especial se espera de este viaje que
Emanuel McQueen pueda hablar en nombre
de toda la Unión Europea
y el servicio geológico de Estados
Unidos informó que el mauna loa el
volcán activo más grande del mundo entró
en erupción en Hawaii aunque los
científicos se mantienen a la espera no
creen que pueda poner en riesgo a la
población nos acerca el volcán yo es muy
el cielo se tornó rojo en Hawaii
mientras cenizas y escombros salían a la
superficie un hecho histórico el mauna
loa entró en erupción es el volcán más
grande en activo y llevaba dormido desde
1984 su periodo de calma más largo desde
que hay registros aunque no ha habido
evacuaciones los científicos son
prudentes no queremos intentar adivinar
el volcán tenemos que dejar que
realmente nos muestre lo que va a hacer
y luego informaremos a la gente de lo
que está sucediendo lo antes posible por
el momento se han abierto dos refugios
como medida de precaución pero no se
cree que haya peligro ni para locales ni
para turistas puesto que la mitad de las
erupciones registradas se limitaron a la
Cumbre sin embargo se está actuando con
prevención ya saben estamos muy
atrasados bueno estábamos muy atrasados
para una erupción del mauna loa y por
eso nos hemos estado preparando
el mauna loa es uno de los cinco
volcanes que forman la isla de Hawai
Ojalá es el único considerado inactivo
son conocidos por su gran tamaño mauna
loa mide 4.169 metros
[Música]
son producidos estos volcanes muy
grandes y anchos que se conocen como
volcanes escudo y eso se debe a que la
composición del magma que entra en
erupción allí es muy fluido
desde hace unas semanas se han activado
las alarmas después de una serie de
temblores algunos ciudadanos están
tomando medidas de prevención pero
acostumbrados a vivir bajo amenaza
aceptan que la diosa de los volcanes
pele fluirá donde y cuando quiera
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en francés 24 y France
24.com enseguida volvemos
[Música]